hello everyone
so it might look normal but this
distribution will ruin your stats what
do I mean by that
a little bit about me first I'm a
Solutions engineer at deep note we build
an amazing data science notebook
platform I'll show you a little bit
later but my real passion for a long
time has been developing statistical
software and we'll see some of that
today
so where are we headed with this talk
well first of all what is a contaminated
normal curve I'm going to describe that
to you and it turns out that
contamination is something we should
expect uh when we're dealing with
Statistics so
um it'll be good to to get caught up on
what this actually means but how does
contamination actually affect our
statistics and I'm going to give you
some live a live demonstration of how
our statistics behave under
contamination and provide some learning
resources for you and of course what can
we do about it and I'll introduce a new
python library that can help deal with
issues of non-robust statistics
so first things first what is a
contaminated normal curve just curious
as you as you're sort of looking at this
chart which distribution do you think is
a standard normal distribution and which
do you think is a contaminated normal
distribution
you can take a second to think about
that
usually when I talk about these things
like 50 50 the room will say oh the
orange one is normal and the other 50
will say oh the blue one is normal it
turns out that the blue curve is
contaminated and the giveaway here is
that if you look at the Tails of the
distribution the blue distribution is as
slightly we say heavier Tails or higher
tails in other words they're just more
outliers
okay but the question is so what what
does this matter well let me explain
something really cool to you so on the
left we've got two populations and
they're separated by a pretty good
effect size there you can see the Peaks
are definitely different I think it's
like 0.8 is the Delta between the two
orange curves those are standard normal
groups then if you focus on the right we
have two other populations they have the
same the same difference between Peaks
okay so it's the same effect size
essentially and uh but the thing is that
those distributions are contaminated
okay and what we want to know is if we
compare the orange groups and look at
how many times we can find a significant
difference and then we also compare the
blue groups together we also want to see
uh you know how many times we're getting
a significant significant difference
and another way of phrasing that is
looking at power so we want to know the
probability of finding a difference or
the probability of finding an effect uh
when there really is one and there
really is one well it turns out that
under normality everything looks great
ninety percent of the time we find a
difference between the left orange curve
and the right orange curve and this is
what we want uh unfortunately though
even if you look to the right uh our
power has gone all the way down to point
two so we only have a 20 chance of
finding an effect when we're doing a a
hypothesis test against these uh
contaminated normal distributions so
that's that's pretty grim
I want to just quickly move over to uh
some resources where you can explore
these Concepts more uh if for whatever
reason you can't see this notebook I'm
sure Logan will jump in and tell me but
anyway we're looking at a deep note
notebook right now it's an interactive
notebook and I'll actually share it with
you later so you can fool around with
these things
um it this is basically a notebook full
of interactive widgets where you can
control or you can set up different
types of populations and see how that
actually affects things like standard
error the average the trimmed mean and
various other different kinds of
statistics and measures and hypothesis
tests and it's all very interactive and
it's meant as a shareable learning
resources if if we go all the way down
though I have this really cool area here
where you can actually
programmatically Define the skewness in
your population and how thick the Tales
are in other words you can make it
contaminated sort of programmatically to
a certain degree and just tldr here and
I obviously I will share this notebook
with you when we increase skewness and
then we compare something like the
percentile bootstrap test which is a
robust hypothesis test to the
traditional t-test which you might have
learned in school which is not robust
when we increase skewness
and we run this we find that the t-test
ends up with a higher probability of
type 1 error so the t-test is not robust
you'll end up saying we found an effect
when there really isn't an effect and
more to the point of this talk when you
increase heaviness okay so this is again
your sort of increasing contamination
you'll find that the t-test actually
falls below the nominal or five percent
error rate that we accept which is an
indication of low power as I showed
before anyway this notebook is full of
really cool interesting thing parameters
you can change it's a really great
resources for students or anyone who's
learning more about robust statistics so
let me come back to my slide
okay
of course the question is so look you've
shown us that uh hey there's some curves
that are contaminated maybe we should
expect outliers in our data sets I think
anyone who's worked with data probably
realized you should expect outliers in
your data sets
um what can you actually do about it
well you can if you uh if you like you
can use this library that I wrote and I
was fortunate enough to write this
library with randar Wilcox who is
um he's a legendary statistician and he
wrote A lot of these functions in R and
I simply moved them over to python so
what hypothesis is is it's a set of
hypothesis tests for comparing groups
and measuring associations so if you are
comfortable with things like t-tests
regression correlation Anova things like
that hypothesize has analogs to all of
those that are very very easy to use and
because it uses trimmed means and
bootstrapping and other robust methods
you don't have to worry about
um type 2 error and type 1 error quite
as much as you do with traditional tests
okay so conclusions what is a
contaminated normal curve well it's
simply actually just a mixture of a
standard normal curve and another
bell-shaped curve with the same mean
where you sort of increase the number of
outliers okay so it's like mixing two
curves one curve that doesn't have any
outliers and one curve that does but
they're both bell shaped and centered at
the same mean and how does contamination
affect our statistics well the typical
typically it leads to incredibly low
power or a wider confidence intervals
and what can we do about it well I just
shared with you that I wrote a library
that can help you uh conduct a robust
hypothesis tests
so uh just wrapping up here quick call
to action if you'd like to uh kindly
give me a star on GitHub that would be
wonderful and if you point your camera
at this QR code you'll get a chance to
uh to have a notebook exactly like the
one I shared with you and you can sort
of interactively learn about these
things yourself
okay thank you very much